it's the word of the day today's word
is
enormous enormous means very large in
size so like something that's really big
like a elephant it's
enormous
is our house
enormous yeah okay you tell me what's
something that's
enormous bberry
Daddy I think we all saw that one coming
what's most interesting about this one
to me is that's actually not what
enormous means a lot of people think
that's what enormous means but enormous
connotes wickedness so you would say the
plot hatched by the terrorist group it
was an enormous plot it was the the
enormity of the attack it denotes size
but also has this kind of evil Bad
connotation to it which has been lost
because people don't read their Strunk
and white anymore